[Applause]
yes this just in the New York Times says
Brett Kavanaugh once threw ice cubes in
a bar
I know ice frozen water shaped like
cubes obviously we can't have this fiend
on the Supreme Court if he treats ice
like a weapon what might he do with a
snow cone now The Times admits the
writer of this piece had once on Twitter
deemed Cavanaugh a threat to society the
times cause calls using this writer in
error
mostly because they got caught once
again but it's ice he's police documents
that show that Brett Kavanaugh threw ice
in someone's face during a bar fight
when he was in college do you feel that
that is in any way disqualifying for
someone to sit in the Supreme Court this
is why we need an FBI investigation
because there are a lot of allegations
and the reports really are about how he
behaves when he is drunk yep
maybe they do want to apologize so you
see what's going on here it's called the
list when initial incidents are
uncorroborated you build a menu of even
more incomplete items to create an
illusion of corroboration first ice then
no geez and finally jaywalking talk
about a petty criminal meanwhile accuser
number three who faced a few allegations
of her own fails to navigate a queue a
did you see Brett Kavanaugh you know
spiking the punch putting reversal I saw
I saw him given Red Solo cups to quite a
few girls during that time frame I saw
him around the punch I won't say bowls
or the punch containers I don't know
what he did but I saw him buy them yes
you know what I'm gonna ask everyone is
wondering if one of those people was
Brett Kavanaugh
I cannot specifically say that he was
one of the ones who assaulted me but
before this happened to me at that party
I saw Brett Kavanaugh there you know her
lawyer cueball Superman
might want to hold off on the
presidential run for now which reminds
me of a joke what's the difference
between a drunk and a journalist
journalists blackout when sober faced
with facts they hate they pass out like
those fainting goats this amnesia oddly
only blocks out stuff that doesn't fit
their desires sweat Nick Ford's
inconsistencies Feinstein's foul play
Rachel Mitchell Michels memo this is
what the media's done to America the
only accusations that matter are against
conservatives no burden of proof no need
for a witness all you need is an
accusation and that accuser then becomes
the prosecutor the left accused then
punished for the cause something we saw
in the Soviet Union and mouthed China
are we there yet
we aren't but the press is Tucker
welcome to the show very exciting to
have you here yes to be here yes so I
just read that Cavanaugh won't be
returning to Harvard to teach so anyone
saying that this is just a job interview
and not some career destroying
Inquisition is lying right the children
at Harvard don't want him yeah and in
fact I think some have filed suit under
title 9 saying his very presence is an
active hostility to the idea of equality
or something this is one of those
moments I've seen a couple in 49 years
where mass hysteria overtakes us all and
I keep thinking as I'm watching these
news reports done by a lot of people I
know yeah these are decent smart people
this is gonna be like waking up with
that tattoo 15 years from now and you're
like I'm not even sure what these tribal
signs stand for and at the time it
seemed deep insignificant and now it's
just embarrassing people are saying
things and attaching significance to
things that are ludicrous that adults
should dismiss out of hand is not
meaningful this is a guy who's written
over 300 opinions as a federal judge
yeah none of them are under debate
instead we're talking about as a
yearbook page and ice cubes and totally
unfounded allegations it's just
embarrassing I believe there's a liberal
case against Brett Kavanaugh a real one
grew these ideas here's why right we're
not hearing that it's this garbage yeah
you know Dana has a tribal tattoo so
you're gonna have to apologize there's
that one time I woke up with tattoo what
do you know you grew up in Colorado
which I believe has snow you probably
packed packed a hard snowball are you
willing to confess it to any snowball
fights you know my grandfather who was a
rancher he was against snowballs because
he had actually seen a boy have his eye
put out by a snow it's always the I do
wonder what will happen with when they
find out that he you know how to put a
spit ball into a young girl's pigtails
in front of him then yeah then we will
know that the nomination is over are the
American public seeing this for what it
is well it depends yeah I don't know I I
don't know I think that they're seeing a
lot of it what was interesting was
yesterday I saw a posting about
interaction on social media about this
issue the number one sites for olives
interaction number one Fox News number
two most Breitbart number three and four
I think we're Ben Shapiro then you hit
like Fox News again like so in terms of
engagement people who are talking about
this interacting about this yes it is
absolutely penetrating I think on the
right for sure but I think it's also
true on the left and you'll see that you
see it in the fundraising number
certainly for Democrats they are raising
a ton of money I don't know so I think
it helps them in the Senate but it could
help them win back the house Jesse would
you like to respond react to some sound
on tape of Donald Trump talking about
this sure why don't we do that let's do
it all right I wanted to ask first okay
you have my permission well I'd say that
it's a very scary time for young men in
America when you can be guilty of
something that you may not be guilty of
it this is a very very is a very
difficult time what's happening here has
much more to do than even the
appointment of a Supreme Court justice I
think he hit the nail on the head
although I'm not worried about anything
I don't think men in this country
much under assault but I will say this
he does have a good point that any
allegation can bring anybody down if
this is the environment we're living in
but let's just get this straight
so someone throws ice at someone at a
bar and Democrats want the FBI to
investigate yes and Hillary Clinton's
classified emails wound up on Anthony
Weiner's laptop two weeks before the
election and the Democrats say no FBI
don't investigate the more and more I
hear about Brett Kavanaugh the more and
more I kind of like Brett Kavanaugh
Brett Kavanaugh likes beer the Democrats
have come out against beer think about
that and I guess this is probably the
dumbest thing they did since they came
out against the national anthem last
year this is terrible politics it sounds
like they want to bring back prohibition
and the last time I checked ed Kennedy
had a few drinks and things didn't go
too well and then the way I get Bill
Clinton was credibly accused of rape by
Juanita Broderick and remember how NBC
treated that they spiked the Juanita
Broderick story and they just went
full-on with this woman's claims and
this woman's being run by as you call
him the creepy porn lawyer who's riddled
in debt and is running for president as
a Democrat none of her alibis check out
she's got a history of Lies and lawsuits
and I'm thinking to myself
NBC News spiked the Ronan Farrow story
about Lansing and they go with this so
they have no standards over there no
it's so true while you can respond to
Jessie or I or you can answer my
question isn't avenatti the best thing
that could happen to Republicans they're
certainly making him into that boy you
would think he was Nancy Pelosi by the
time they're done well has he done
anything good for the Democrats I don't
know I mean clearly avenatti had stormy
Daniels I don't think that's a very
figure she said no I'm going where it's
my cue ball here oh no but let me just
say Jesse's yes that's these press ease
affection for judge Kavanagh as a fellow
frat boy I think that's so that's what
it is because this story unlike what you
guys are talking about is about the
judges credibility and if he's in the
bar engaging with bar fights and you say
throwing ice to make the big deal no
this is a guy who says he was a choirboy
he said nothing like this was going to
say he was a choirboy basically did
he was a berry like beer that's a fire
boy in the president's comment great yes
oh these are scarier times scary times
for young men and then Don junior Don
juniors on record saying he's more
afraid for his sons than he is for his
daughters Wow so in other words
Professor Ford who steps forward puts
her name out there comes forward and
testifies before Congress
professor Ford oh no your trauma your
difficulty your lifetime of trauma is to
be ignored now what we're really worried
about is the boys how ridiculous is this
why you haven't you have sons when you
worry one thing never to process this is
not he was not charged with a crime this
is about him going to the supreme court
of public opinion states could be worse
and here's the thing Greg if you put
someone on you say oh well did he lie
did it dissemble oh so he says that
specifically he said he had no knowledge
about this New Yorker article and it
turns out guess what he's trying to get
people to refute now there's one
question you you said like many say that
this is not a legal proceeding it's a
job interview therefore due process
doesn't apply the rules of basic
fairness don't apply is that really the
standard you want due process isn't is a
legal term for fairness yeah if I accuse
you of something I have to show that you
did it that doesn't just apply to court
that applies to how you raise your kids
how you deal with your wife and your
coworkers
do we really suspend that because
Democrats want power I mean are you
actually comfortable that's not about
suspending cuz Democrats want power
suspending the idea that somehow this is
- you're to have the rules of a Criminal
Procedure says you're accused prove
you're innocent are you it's not they
actually say that out loud are you know
that's not you I mean you are distorting
it the real I'm not a potentate let me
by the way you are not as attractive as
most people who sit in this chip
when you say no Dana needs to clarify
what you say so there is something that
is unfair about this suggestion that
Brett Kavanaugh was trying to coach
people through text messages so that
they would corroborate a story like that
they knew was come out of New Yorker
that it's not the case that is not what
happened and having been the
spokesperson for Robertson Toledo let me
just tell you like for example you have
so many press questions coming at you
about things that might have happened
like John Roberts the big scandal was
that he was a member of the Federalist
Society what do I have to do I got it
calls him I was like was John Roberts a
member of the Pharaoh Society like what
happened there did he give a speech
there like I'm trying to figure it out
so yes I have to ask them about it it's
not because you're trying to squash a
story that's unfair it's not you know
the best defense I thought you were
going to say it's possible that the
reporter for The New Yorker was in touch
with his advisors and maybe even him and
then he reached out to people but
remember Dana he testified that he knew
nothing about this until you testify he
didn't know and the specific allegation
was he had gotten wind that this woman
was calling around you know why she was
calling around because she didn't know
it was Kavanaugh she was saying to her
friends hey you know what was a
Kavanaugh I'm not really sure so he had
gotten wind something was coming down
the pipeline so he said to some of his
buddies hey you know why like I didn't
do anything let's make sure I just like
the fact that Jesse is doing the old
symbol for a telephone to much for you
great I know you don't want to hear the
other side we're three minutes over okay
we have to talk about Tucker's book all
right president Trump Democrats in his
potential 2020 photo
the parts ahead